[Applause]
new york isn't dead the new york boom
might be dead temporarily yeah so look
20 years who knows
that's what that's what bothered me
about the al touch article right it's
like he
acted like since new york is isn't
constantly inflating its own economy
and pricing the people who live here out
that is dead
it's like that's not how it works
everything is an ebb and flow
right and way i look at this like
honestly well it's like
a blessing in a lot of ways right
because like we have some old
it's like a snake that's what new york
is is a [ __ ] snake okay
and it's shedding its skin and the old
gotta go
there's no reason why jerry should be
living in new york there's no reason why
james should be live in new york you
guys are built for the suburbs that's
what's for you
right new york is for the young it's for
the hungry it's for the hustlers like
i'm telling you i'm saying this right
now and i guarantee there are people in
new york that are thinking the exact
same thing
new yorkers don't get me wrong there is
economic insecurity
but this is a hustle city there are
people here already finding ways to make
money like
people have printed obama is the new
president t-shirt
before they he won they were waiting on
times square
ready to sell those [ __ ] shirts like
this is the hustle city
so people are going to find a way to get
money in new york yeah they're going to
find a way to take advantage of it and
like i'm looking through that that
article he said
because i wrote a couple things down he
was like the
the time life building is empty this
this
what do you say the rockefeller center
is empty like
good who cares like nobody's going to
rockefeller center like there's so many
more interesting places to go check out
in new york city besides rockefeller
center
or the [ __ ] time life building do i
think the point to this is that
like new york had so much like deep
culture and it had like authentic new
york
like people living here and it was these
kinds of people that moved in
and killed new york in the first year
yes if any if if new york was dying it
was from these yuppies moving in yes
he is those kinds of people but he's a
new yorker who
although oh altitude yeah no he is a new
yorker and i give him that but at the
same time he is also representing those
like hedge fund douchebags and all that
kind of stuff like yeah that's what
people realize like when you talk about
the new york real estate market
we talk about this all the time like you
have perspective because you come from a
place where you can buy a home for 175
a home a decent home 475 back at least
in the ni
2000's decent you could get a decent
home right so like new york's real
estate market
they're like oh it's going down 20 it's
going down 30
is so inflated by people who aren't even
living here
right new york real estate especially
manhattan real estate was the most safe
investment in the world so what do
people with money in countries that suck
do
take their money they hide it in a
building in new york
right they buy some [ __ ] apartments
you look at these apartment buildings
there's apartment building right next to
it that big glass one where we were
growing up
or when we were living together near
there right
half vacant it was just chinese people
bought the apartments never moved in oh
yeah yeah yeah so what happens when
people buy apartments they don't even
rent them
now they're scarcity of apartments yeah
those other apartments that are left
cost way more right now us new yorkers
are being penalized because
[ __ ] are hiding their money
here
so now if it isn't as safe a bet to
invest in new york
good why should we be penalized for
making our city dope
like we make it cool the artists the
entrepreneurs the creators come in here
make it fire the chefs the people to
open a small cool little restaurant make
a neighborhood hip
we make it fire these yuppies come in
because they want to take advantage of
it
they ruin whatever neighborhood they
come into so we make another
neighborhood cool
right that's why we're in this
neighborhood right now because the cool
kids are continuing to move further out
because that's the only [ __ ] they could
afford
right right new york's not dead because
people are leaving it's dead because
people are coming
yeah these [ __ ] nerds come in right
and then when it's not comfy for these
nerds to do their nerd [ __ ] no more or
to take more money out of the city
right yeah they say it's that the
audacity
for you to not be able to profit as much
as you used to profit in the city
yeah off of what we create now you say
it's
dead because you can't suck any more
wealth out of it
[ __ ] you yeah this [ __ ] been lost it's a
beautiful time man i love you gonna have
the rich move out and you're gonna have
the transplants
also that can't take it in new york
movie bye now
new yorkers will actually be able to
take advantage of new york and you know
what else is kind of nice for the first
time
i'm looking to move back in if i can
again my girl subber girl i am too but
she's more scared of it
but the nice buildings that these
yuppies all got rent's going down yeah
now for a decent amount of rent you
could have a nice building in new york
and i know
some of y'all think about but what about
the landlords that own these places
that's me
i'm getting abused by this and you know
what i'm okay with it
i'm okay that's fine this is the ebb and
flow the natural ebb and flow
of the market and if real estate prices
need to come down that's what the [ __ ]
needs to happen
if it's up to me i'd rather new york
with tons of young cool
creative hungry [ __ ] not some
dudes sitting on billions of dollars
just collecting interest and taking up
all the reservations at the cool
restaurants
you [ __ ] the city up for us so when
you say new york is dead that's just
insulting because it implies
that new york is alive because of uh
implants or transplants
it's never been that you all have taken
advantage of what we created
so if you want to beat it fine beat it
bye
see ya
you